covered 19 can have devastating effects
for the lungs but doctors and nurses are
discovering new damaging effects every
day from cardiac arrest to kidney
failure and even unexplained tissue
growth it's a trial it's it's a marathon
really a new more holistic understanding
of the disease is emerging can it lead
to better treatments and higher survival
rates
now months have passed since coronavirus
entered our lives but we're still
learning about what it's capable of a
disease that may begin its assault in
the lungs is proven it can wreak havoc
on many other parts of the body but as
our understanding increases so does our
ability to fight covered 19 Kirsten
Meyer is a junior doctor on the
intensive care unit in HoN overs dia Co
very Hospital since March the hospitals
mainly cared for severely ill cope at 19
patients Meyer says dealing with an
unknown virus was a challenge to begin
with and that she was stunned by how
quickly some patients would slip beyond
help Nordic we're here talking with us
even making calls to their families then
two hours later we have to ventilate
them the doctors on the unit keep all
patients under close observation
constantly measuring their blood oxygen
levels and sharing their impressions
with one another it's becoming apparent
that kovat 19 is not only about the
lungs it damages the kidneys too they
all get blood thinners those are things
you gradually learn on the job but it's
not purely a pathological lung condition
it's something that really affects the
whole body she always worked researchers
like Danny Yannick can use that kind of
experience
he says the corona virus has little in
common with influenza a pathologists at
Hanover mhh Hospital Yannick and his
team analyzed tissue samples from
deceased kovat 19 patients their
findings are staggering we've come to
realize that almost 50% of intensive
care patients actually develop acute
kidney failure it's just that the lungs
get to them before that does Yannick
sees cope in 19 as less of a lung
affliction and much more of a vascular
illness a severely ill coronavirus
patient develops embolisms or blockages
in blood vessels on top of that
within hours uncontrolled excess tissue
growth sets
Mohandas or the oxygen demand is
probably so great that under the stress
of infection the body tries to supply
itself with more oxygen by creating new
blood vessels but it doesn't work Yonex
findings have spread rapidly through the
medical world as a result 12
international teams have formed to
continue with the research does the
virus cause excess tissue growth or is
it the body's final cry for help we
still don't know if the fresh blood
vessel tissue the major new discovery
we've made actually is something which
is positive or negative is it perhaps
something that shouldn't be triggered or
is it beneficial and needs encouragement
a school doesn't target since villages
the answer could offer the basis for new
ways of treating kovat 19 but since it
will probably take a few more years to
understand doctors like Kirsten Meyer
will have to keep a vigilant eye on
their patients well let's speak to
Christophe spinner he's a consultant
physician in infectious diseases at the
Technical University of Munich thanks
for joining us dr. Shapiro so we know
coronavirus starts to attack the body
via the airways and lungs but what we
didn't what do we know about its effect
on other parts of the body
well securing the first wave of the
Kovach 19 pandemic and they make we have
learned pretty much while we expected in
the very beginning isolated lung
involvement we now have learned that SAS
cough 2 can already affect every cell of
the body and this results in like my
heart affection and many other
complications that we have seen
including pulmonary embolism or embolism
in general and this is somewhat
challenging for us physician because the
variety of Kovach 19 disease is huge is
it a very different to the disease to
what we thought we were dealing with
just a few months ago I think
Banta to this question is clearly yes
because what we expected in the very
beginning is the respiratory disease
lung involvement or involvement and
pneumonia was the most common expected
symptom combined with fever and coughing
but now we've recognized that many other
complications including strokes and
others can severely affect patients
being infected with SARS coronavirus -
and is much more to learn about the
virus and its cause because the disease
causes is very different from very mild
to asymptomatic ones but also patients
being severely affected resulting in the
need for mechanical ventilation from
many weeks and it is about to understand
what the different reasons for this is
and when it does affect other parts of
the body - you know just the lungs does
that mean it takes greater skill to
treat it well to our understanding from
today we have understood that South
coronavirus - is affecting the entire
body that means this systemic disease
and not a primary lung disease but in
terms of the treatment only systemic
treatments have been explored or
clinical studies focused to systemic
treatments while there is different
categories that means antiviral concepts
but also anti-inflammatory concepts
because what we've understood so far is
that the viral replication itself is a
problem but also the immune activation
due to sarcoma virus to infection and
therefore these two different approaches
or combined ones are currently under
investigation and we are constantly
learning more about this disease on wait
so is the way we treat it also
constantly changing well I think yes
because run decimated the first
antiviral substance or drug that is
available in the US and will become
available in the European Union very
soon is a first step but we've also
learned that dexamethasone a steroid
that is reducing immune activity is also
decreasing mortality and
ability of disease in CBA Kovach 19
patients but there is a couple of
hundred other drugs being under
investigation and also other concepts of
treatment and while the affection of
Kovac 19 is very different around the
world it is very clear that we will
learn from the ongoing studies within
the next month pretty much more about
fighting against Kovac 19 so how much is
there left to learn about covered 19 we
obviously learned a lot over the past
few months but is there more well the
speed of research we have seen in terms
of Saskatoon is amazing I've never seen
such speed in increasing medical
knowledge before but this is very
important and as the entire world is
fighting a big 19 I think there will be
much more novel ideas and mobile aspects
that will help us in fighting against
this disease dr. Krystof spinor from the
Technical University of Munich thank you
very much for joining us thank you and
now it's your chance to ask the
questions here's our science
correspondent Derek Williams
what's the d6 one 4G mutation the d6 one
4G mutation is a mutation in a variant
of the virus that's predominantly found
in Europe and most of the US and and
there's been lots of speculation it
might be linked to either higher
fatalities or or higher transmissibility
in patients one study from the US that
still under peer review claims to show
the mutation makes the virus much more
infectious by by stabilizing and
increasing its number of spikes though
those are those proteins that stars co2
you
is to attach to cells but those
researchers were only working with cell
cultures so so their results don't
necessarily translate one to one in the
real world
though other studies have supported the
idea that the d6 one 4G variant is more
transmissible it'll take more work to
find out if the mutation really does
make it more infectious in us rather
than just in ourselves in culture why is
kovat 19 considered a pandemic when less
than 1% of the world's population has
been infected currently only around one
person in a thousand or so on the planet
has been officially listed as a kovat 19
case which which doesn't sound like much
so i understand your confusion and and
the term is a little fluid the w-h-o
which which by the way sat on the fence
for weeks and the early stages of the
outbreak before deciding to call kovat
19 a pandemic defines pandemic pretty
simply as the worldwide spread of a new
disease so all it is is an epidemic but
one that spread over a number of
countries or continents and is moving
swiftly and affecting large numbers of
people however the word isn't attached
or tied to a specific number what's the
probability of significant damage being
inflicted on the lungs in an otherwise
asymptomatic case the problem with
trying to answer this question is the
word asymptomatic it's a it's a very
loose term but what we're discovering is
that even if someone doesn't really
notice that they have the disease it
doesn't necessarily mean it hasn't
damaged their lungs in a small-scale
study from China over half of these
supposedly asymptomatic kovat 19
subjects actually had CT scan patterns
indicative of lung damage caused by by
mild forms of pneumonia we'll need much
more extensive research
however to determine whether that number
is accurate and and figuring it out is
not going to be easy after all I mean
most asymptomatic cases are never
discovered simply because the patient
doesn't even know they're sick so why
would you scan their lungs the good news
is that lung specialists are cautiously
optimistic that that in most
asymptomatic patients any damage that's
done will heal over time
[Music]